hello Tech Enthusiast Welcome to our
Channel where we delve into the
fascinating world of technology today we
are tackling a topic that sparked
endless debates in the Tech Community
Linux versus Windows it's a showdown
between the freedom of Open Source and
the familiarity of a household name
whether you are a seasoned programmer a
casual user or somewhere in between this
comparison is for you we will explore
the intri cases strengths and qus of
each system so sit back grab your
favorite snack and let's dive into the
world of operating systems it's Linux
versus Windows the battle of the OS
Giants begins now and before starting
just a quick info for you if you are an
aspiring cyber security professional
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply
Larn postgraduate program in cyber
security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
your right choice through our courses
you will gain knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like Advanced
hacking Concepts Network packet analysis
ethical hacking network security and
over a dozen others and that's not all
you also get the opportunity to work on
multiple projects and learn from
industry experts working in top tier
product and security companies and
academicians from top universities this
course is designed to accommodate a
diverse range of Learners and this
course requires just a bachelor's degree
with a 50% average and no prior
programming experience and one plus year
of work experience is preferred if you
are passionate about making your career
in this field then make sure to check
out the link in the pin comment and
description box to find a cyber security
program that fits your experience and
areas of Interest now moving back to our
topic that is Linux versus Windows so
Linux an open- source and complimentary
operating system debuted in 1991
courtesy of lus stals while he was a
student at the University city of henai
drawing its foundation from the Unix
system Linux is acclaimed for its robust
stability enhanced security and
versatile adaptability it's extensively
utilized across various platforms
including servers supercomputers mobile
devices embedded systems and desktop
computers on the other side Microsoft is
the architect behind the proprietary
operating system Windows launched
initially as Windows 1.0 in 1985 it
served as as a graphical overlay for the
MS St system over the years Windows has
evolved through numerous substantial
Updates this operating system is
prevalent across a broad spectrum of
devices encompassing personal computers
tablets and other similar Technologies
while Linux has established dominance in
server and supercomputer applications
Windows enjoy widespread popularity in
the personal Computing realm Windows is
often loaded for its userfriendly
interface whereas Linux is celebrated
for its formidable stability and
security features in the past few years
Linux has seen a surge in its adoption
as a desktop operating system this rise
in popularity can be attribute primarily
to the emergence of accessible and
userfriendly versions like ub2 and mint
despite this Windows continues to
maintain its stronghold as the global
preferred desktop operating system
nevertheless Linux is steadily carving
out a significant Niche for itself in
the market now moving to the difference
between Linux versus Windows so starting
with first that is Windows uses
different data drives like CDE to store
files and folders and whereas Linux uses
a tree like a hierarchical file system
Linux files are ordered in a tree
structure starting with the root
directory whereas in Windows files are
stored in folders on different data
drives like C C D or E now moving to the
next difference that is hard drives CD
RS printers are considered as devices
and whereas in Linux peripherals like
hard drives CD RS printers are also
considered files in Linux or Unix
systems now moving to the next
difference that is there are four types
of user account types in Windows that is
administrator standard child and guest
whereas in Linux there are three types
of user account types regular root and
service account moving to the next
difference so Windows administrator user
has all administrative privileges of
computers and in Linux root user is the
super user and has all administrative
Privileges and now moving to the next
one so in Windows you cannot have two
files with the same name in the same
folder whereas in Linux you can have
that is the naming convention is case
sensitive the sample and the case
uppercase sample are two different files
in Linux or Unix operating system and
mov to the next difference in Windows my
documents is default home directory
whereas in Linux for every user
directory is created which is called his
home directory and talking about more so
Linux is an open source operating system
so user can change source code as per
requirement whereas Windows OS is a
commercial operating system so user
doesn't have access to source code and
Linux is very well secured as it is easy
to detect bugs and fix whereas Windows
has a huge user base so it becomes a
target of hackers to attack Windows
system and if we compare Windows File
system versus Linux file system Linux
runs faster even with older Hardware
whereas windows are slower compared to
Linux and in Linux as you can see you
can have two files with the same name
and in lenux you would find the system
and program files in different
directories whereas in Windows system
and program files are usually saved in C
drive and that's wrap up our Deep dive
into the Linux versus Windows Saga we
hope this journey has shed light on
these two Powerhouse operating systems
and perhaps even helped you decide which
Camp you are in are you team lenux with
its robust security and open source
charm or do you lean towards the
userfriendly and widespread appeal of
Windows let us know in the comment
section below we love hearing your
thoughts and experiences if you enjoyed
this video don't forget to hit like
share sh with your friends and subscribe
to our channel for more Tech insights
and comparisons keep exploring keep
questioning and until next time stay
curious staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains and including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here